over time for Jon Meacham how would you
compare president Trump's conduction
conduction Oh Trump in the world bet you
are just qualified for finishing that
question or Jon Meacham how would you
assess trums grasp of history give him a
great job move on okay will HR McMaster
be forced out of the administration due
to the old right campaign against him by
the way that also looks like it's
coordinated with Russia well then it's
very sad because I mean the one thing
you have that you hope for with Trump is
that there are these grown-ups around
him and you know there are serious
people the odd thing about the McMaster
appointment was you know it's sort of
what you say with trumpian the policy
seems irrelevant to him in the sense
that you know at one point he was for
universal health care at another point
is for a total repeal of Obamacare it's
sort of like anything just give me a win
right he does so so wasn't we with
McMaster HR McMaster is a brilliant
military officer whose whole thesis is
exactly the opposite of what prompt
campaigning on his a you go into these
countries big you stay there forever you
were here to work with the locals as
well as the counterinsurgency and I'm
thinking myself how do you do this
because they met for 10 minutes and
mar-a-lago and the sofa in the lobbying
and even like good man you've got a lot
of medals on I like that
what is alright saying against him who
mcmaster oh well nothing that's the
theme pan and wing of the doesn't like
him because apparently he's been he's
been moderating from Ponce he's saying
he's got to go oh we want action Richard
Dawkins why do people think of atheists
as immoral do they do they think of it
they do it's well known that they do and
it's bizarre actually because if you
think about why they think that it's
because they think that we don't have a
God we're looking over our shoulder
supervising everything a great spy
camera in the sky looking at us so we
must be amoral it's the only reason
you're moral if you think you're being
supervised I don't want to know you but
also I think it's because they think the
Ten Commandments are in the Bible and
therefore that's the SuperDuper great
list of they don't know what the Ten
Commandments are I mean that's true too
I shall have no other God but me that's
what make no no graven image they know
about thou shalt not kill right
Christopher Hitchens made a good remark
about that Moses comes down from the
mountain of this tablet and says thou
shalt not kill Oh thou shalt not kill we
never thought of that I mean I mean
every day it's such a dumb list it only
ever meant thou shalt not kill members
of thine own tribe right that's your
true ya only two of them are laws don't
kill and don't steal I mean the first
four I think are just about God's ego
yeah yes good kind of you if you were
going to make a list of the 10 absolute
things you shouldn't do you wouldn't
care about graven images or statues and
swearing you might include incest
you know pederasty you might include
some of these rape that's not on the lid
that those things don't make the had a
wonderful professor once who explained
that particularly in leviticus where
they have those yeah very careful
prohibitions thou shalt not have sex
with goats yes no one would think to
write that if people weren't having
right it's not something that we just
say hey and this e and then see does the
admonition against wearing hemp yeah
things like that is full of these
bizarre again yes not always but in
leviticus that was that was a earmark
from the cotton man it was the giga you
know is it like somebody then like
polyester oh no what and you know we
know that the bible is an anthology it's
it's not written by one person but by
many different authors and they left
some out i mean there are like DVD
extras of the banner of i'm sure there
are other books around let may company
decided we're going to put this in it
they could have saved themselves so much
pain by not putting in like really
Dawkins ian moral obligation to say that
his bill knows that he's very sweet i'm
the diversity here I am an Episcopalian
we barely count as Christians anymore
but but it's also one of the think more
markable things about the Bible is it is
a translation of a translation of a
translation right and those who think it
is somehow another FedExed in on Amazon
Prime Oh God is really that we're
reading an English version of Hebrew and
Greek text that were copied they weren't
photocopied these are people so what if
a month dropped in and not when he
wasn't supposed to write you know along
along this but that actually make it has
made it much easier to interpret the
Bible liberally over the years and one
of the great problems for liberal
Muslims has always been that the Quran
is seen as the direct Word of God and so
it's more difficult to claim that this
stuff is less important whereas with the
Bible there's this rich tradition of
saying well these are just stories about
God and as you say they were put
together and so maybe Leviticus isn't
that important in the Sermon on the
Mount is I means always struck me as
bizarre that
fundamentalist Christians based so much
attention to these prohibitions you know
that are that are mine and but the main
point of the New Testament as far as I
can tell is being be nice to poor people
and be suspicious of rich people like
that is the fantasy in a frontal center
over and over again and somehow that's
kind of gotten between to the sidelines
until this Pope
kind of reminded people actually that's
the big deal in Christianity right yeah
okay what does the panel think of the
feud between Donald Trump and Mitch
McConnell funny stuff yeah you know he
knew he founded who Mitch McConnell was
about three weeks ago
[Music]
he thought he was you know a country
doctor from Kentucky it's it's yet
another case of Washington experience
can be way overrated unquestionably but
you at least need to have an
old-fashioned face book you know when
you get there and know these people are
and I think that he's it's an attempt to
in this relentlessly solipsistic
narcissistic White House anyone who does
not come in and bow the knee is out and
McConnell won't do it well it's a
particular I've been following the story
he's mad at Mitch McConnell for not
getting the repeal of Obamacare done and
see this is I think great argument for
why the Republican theory that a
businessmen would be great as president
is silly because in trumps world I don't
think he ever cared about details and
his whole modus operandi was always just
if a guy doesn't do it right I'll get
somebody else yeah you can't get the job
done I replace you like I did with my
wives for instance so that's what he
thinks he doesn't get into the details
he's like Mitch didn't get it done I'll
find something to get it done just like
I got rid of the mooch and I got rid of
this one and I got rid of this wouldn't
it okay throwing bodies out until I get
somebody he doesn't realize there's no
body that can get it
done right because it's a [ __ ] bill
right right okay Jim Parsons who has
been your favorite guest on your podcast
I hate that question it's okay no it's
okay I was most excited I shouldn't that
that sounds awful I'm judging them but I
did talk to John McCain and I was very
surprised he bothered Wow John McCain
I'm get yeah I couldn't get him on this
show no you know what can you talk can
you talk to anymore because I will have
my people call him and tell me you're
not as bad as you seem on TV that's very
funny
I really never forgot like somebody told
him it was safe to come right I really
don't know who that was but it was he
was funny she's so hard to predict John
McCain yeah I mean like you hate him one
minute and next even if he comes through
very you know it's got a flair for the
dramatic doesn't either
I love that okay all right thank you
everybody you were great
[Applause]